sometimes we don't notice them but they
are all around us today electrical
appliances are making our lives a lot
easier if we're to enjoy the power of
electricity we have to master it in
Europe to protect citizens against all
health and safety risks when using
electrical appliances the European
Commission promotes the most demanding
standards
these guarantee the highest levels of
safety and quality for European
electrical products and ensure the most
efficient use of energy in order to meet
the Europe 2020 climate change target
all of this contributes to the stability
of the sector employing 2.8 million
Europeans
switching Europe arm European Union
policy on electrical goods